[Music]
hey welcome to certified country I'm
Sophie she lacy luke combs is with us in
the studio today congratulations are in
order for the deluxe album yes thank you
very much
so exciting what can the fans expect
they're getting four brand-new songs and
then I rerecorded my song she got the
best of me so five tracks and total
added on to the records I had you know
written a ton of songs and I get pretty
impatient having to like keep them all
balled up I guess so I kind of released
some of them I would played him in some
radio shows and put some on Facebook
everything and so people seem to love
those Tunes and I guess the idea was
this was a way to give him the songs
they had been asking for without you
know having to you know put a whole
record out but we have recorded even
more music outside of the villas but but
it's a it's kind of a good tide over
from now and to record too crazy she can
amaze me
in your time in the industries who's
giving you the best advice
Brantley he's giving me a ton of great
advice he's kind of run the gamut from
the club shows all the way to the big
games here thing what's the best thing
he's told you he told me to hear about
the fans and he said listen we're doing
it for these people so we cater our show
to them we cater meet-and-greets to them
and the music for them because without
them you know there's no show and
there's no reason for us to play if
nobody's gonna come and so I've really
really tried to take that to heart and
make the show be totally what the fans
want and the same with the deluxe you
know as they said hey we want these
homes to come out and so that's the
songs we recorded and that's the song as
we put out it sounds like such simple
advice but I know how tough it can be
when you're in the business of it how
easy it is to forget that kind of stuff
it is it definitely would be I mean cuz
you're doing so many things and I think
if you're having a string of sold-out
shows or whatever you're like well
people are just always gonna show up and
I don't think that's true
I want to ask you a rapid-fire round
five questions first album you've ever
purchased may be Backstreet Boys Nirvana
probably is up there
Will Smith probably Will Smith for the
same era that was what was big though we
were so about consuming music wow Big
Willie saw
get jiggy with it that's it right there
that's a big record first concert you
ever attended Vince Gill 1996 Charlotte
Knights minor-league baseball stadium
and I left because I was six and I
started crying
song currently spinning on repeat I'm
amigo Skye
sounds weird post my own guy okay love
that guy I've been playing that John
party record since it came out a lot of
stuff spinning on the bus right now
run spanning a disease genre lies
artists wise anything would you ever do
a rap collaboration and I don't know I
mean I think it would have to be like
the perfect thing like I wouldn't want
it to feel contrived like I don't
wouldn't want it to feel like we're
trying to get plays and spins things
like it has to be cool and a house it
would have to be the right thing I would
I'd give a shot now if you weren't an
artist you'd probably be doing what get
this question a lot and I always answer
with homeless no um I don't know I guess
if the artist thing wasn't working out I
would probably still try to just be a
songwriter what is one thing we've never
guessed by looking at you I have two
cats never guess that always assuming
I'm a dog guy which I am I love dogs but
I live in an apartment yeah I'm not
really home a lot so no I have I had a
cat from a previous relationship when we
split up by somehow I ended up with the
cat she's pretty cool though that's
pretty cool and then my girlfriend now
she got a cat so now we're a two cat
household cat daddy cat daddy what are
you record - cat dad we combs cat dad
home - thank you so much for being here
source I'm talking to you know thank you
guys so much for watching if this is
your first time with us please subscribe
to Entertainment Tonight on YouTube we
have new episodes of certified country
each and every Friday so we'll see you
next week